ja man kann erstmal beruhigen reise in
richtung der verbraucher sagen dass der
grundsatz gilt ohne leistung kein geld
also sprich wenn man jetzt keine
leistung bekommen kann dann kann man in
aller regel auch sein geld
zurückverlangen
in aller regel da ist um so eine kleine
einschränkung die resultiert fast schon
von dem ersten doktor und so kann man es
fast sagen da gab es nämlich ein gesetz
was dazu eingeführt wurde was im mai
diesen jahres in kraft getreten ist und
da ist geregelt dass jemand der vor dem
8 märz 2020 karten gekauft hat oder ein
fitnessstudio abo abgeschlossen hat dass
der entgegen des grundsatzes kein geld
ersatz bekommt dann sondern dass der
eben auf einen gutschein verwiesen
werden darf da gibt es natürlich
ausnahmeregelungen aber für jemanden der
sozusagen vor dem 8 märz schon tickets
gekauft hat der wird wahrscheinlich
einen gutschein akzeptieren müssen
auch wenn mein konzert jetzt immer
wieder verschoben wird also muss jedes
mal wieder ein gutschein in kauf nehmen
die viele konzert in diesem jahr wurden
ja bereits verschoben auf kommendes jahr
jetzt weiß man da auch nicht so richtig
ob das funktioniert kann ich irgendwann
sagen jetzt reicht's damit ja in der tat
gibt es eine deadline also nächstes jahr
jahresende wer bis zum 31 12 2021 so ist
die gesetzliche regelung den gutschein
nicht nehmen konnte oder nicht genommen
hat der bekommt dann sein geld zurück
und fitnessstudios da haben wir fast
alle verträge die jahresverträge oder
was auch immer und da kann ich jetzt
schon wieder nicht hingehen ist das ein
kündigungsgrund
nein also die fitnessstudios die können
natürlich auch nichts dafür da wird ja
ich quasi der vertrag aber ein
kündigungsgrund ist das nicht also da
klares signal in richtung verbraucher
das ist nicht gut aus für eine kündigung
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren